is there a
I feel like we always hear about people
who who are inside of that family and
how like it comes with a lot of pressure
because obviously it's the most famous
family in the world you know what I'm
saying is there any truth to that like
once you kind of get into that
Kardashian gang there's just things
change in terms of like obviously you
have a lot more eyes on you but do you
feel that pressure is it like palatable
where's pressure but I'm an athlete
Championship athlete
if anybody
had a little pressure with me yeah
I didn't handle the power
I'm good you feel me yeah is there's
power that comes with that [ __ ] for sure
yeah
were you uh were you around yay at all
when he was yeah he was playing the
music for me
his new new [ __ ] for me when I was
recovering
damn I [ __ ] with him for that
yeah
yeah Kanye seems I mean he seems like a
pretty misunderstood guy man he's one
he's my favorite artist ever though I
got a poster yeah so I got all these
albums I mean Nas is my favorite MC yeah
but in terms of artists discography yeah
it's yay yeah love you amen
I think yeah
it's so crazy I listen to some of his
[ __ ] now I'm I realize how good it is
what what how do you remember which
album he was playing you while you're in
the hospital
what year was it I could probably tell
you it was
2015. oh it was the life of Pablo that's
what I was just to say I think it was
the life of Pablo yeah because that came
out in 2016. yeah that's fire [ __ ] all
the new [ __ ] that [ __ ] woke my soul up
because I was really dead
at that time I think that's what like I
kind of like
lost Chloe because my mind I couldn't
really
um
express myself how I was feeling express
my thoughts
yeah
you know what I mean yeah after not
being able to talk [ __ ] took me a little
while to learn how to talk and walk
again that's crazy man I can only
imagine you had to write [ __ ] down hold
up yeah and it's not like even if you
write something down you ain't really
getting out your thoughts like how you
want to get them out this is it's not
with the fluidity right
yeah that's crazy man